uh there's a phrase that i really love
which some of the stuff i i know this
makes me sound like a total pollyanna
but it's not happy people who are
grateful it's grateful people who are
happy yeah i love it i love that you
probably do the same thing i do it's
like i have a gratitude list and anytime
i'm down i just look at my phone and
it's a list of things i'm grateful for
and like you know number one is like
my wife my two is like you know
my my first son number three is my
second son
but then there's some random things on
there alexis yep like what my favorite
pizza place uh like there's one thing
there it says that i've achieved many of
my goals without having to destroy my
soul in the process like you know i like
random things like that listed that i i
can still get out and play basketball
uh you know like somewhat competitively
uh yeah which which is something that
that i'm proud of so they're like things
where it's like oh i am grateful for
that i'm grateful for that too like you
know some of them are kind of minor and
dumb but yeah that always makes me feel
better to your point that grateful
people are happy so anyone listening to
this if you're down and i know sometimes
it's hard not to be down in this day and
age just make yourself a list of things
you're grateful for and add something to
it every once in a while at any time
yeah you're down at the dumps just refer
to it and will help and that's not just
me saying so that's like that's data
this stuff totally works right we're
nothing if not data backed so i would
agree 100 percent
[Music]
this week on forward i sit with comedian
and podcaster alexis gay and she's the
interviewer it's for her podcast
non-technical which is meant to unearth
human aspects of various prominent
figures i guess i'm prominent for this
one yang gang hope you enjoy
[Music]
hello hello and welcome to non-technical
where i your host alexis gay interview
influential folks from tech media
business and beyond about everything
except their resumes today on the pod
big pod honestly you're thinking of
hyping it too much but you're not ready
we have andrew yang entrepreneur author
and former u.s presidential and nyc
mayoral candidate so he's done a lot of
other super impressive very interesting
things prior to that which admittedly
i'm not going to ask him that much about
andrew thank you so much for being here
it's great to be here with you alexis i
admire your work i do prefer just to
talk about my resume though so if we
could just
stick to that that would be delightful
you know i get that a lot i understand
people love to talk about work we can't
get enough of it genuinely when this hit
my radar and my team said hey do you
want to do this i was like [ __ ] yeah
because i don't have to talk about the
same [ __ ] i mean that'd be delightful
exactly no i'm very passionate about my
work and i love it dearly
but you know what i mean you're like let
the record show i'm very passionate
about my work however i would love to
not talk about it for 50 minutes that's
right
all right are you ready to dive in
sure fantastic let's do it
andrew yang is an entrepreneur author
philanthropist non-profit leader and
former u.s presidential and new york
city mayoral candidate after being a
corporate lawyer for five short months
joining a few startups and even
launching his own company andrew
eventually became ceo of an education
company that became number one in the
country he then started a national
entrepreneurship non-profit venture for
america leading the organization to
become a national multi-million dollar
charity andrew was named a presidential
ambassador of entrepreneurship by the
white house under the obama
administration and a champion of change
for his leadership in late 2017 andrew
decided to run for president with a
vision to rewrite the rules of the
united states economy his movement
around universal basic income and cash
relief engaged over 3 million combined
social media followers raised nearly 40
million dollars and became one of the
most exciting stories in the 2020 race
as an activist andrew has turned his
movement into a political reality
launching a non-profit humanity forward
that has successfully lobbied congress
to bring billions of dollars in cash
relief and stimulus checks to millions
of americans in need he's the author of
three books including his newest work
forward outlining the problems he sees
in the american system and a way forward
to prevent the decline of democracy he
currently lives in manhattan with his
wife evelyn and two boys is an avid
basketball fan and commentator on cnn
host of a weekly podcast yang speaks as
well as serves as the founder of the
forward party aiming to fix our broken
duopoly andrew yang welcome to
non-technical oh thank you alexis um
it's great to be with you it's such a
pleasure to be with you i usually use
this time to say how i know the guest or
how we've interacted before but i think
that speaks for itself and first and
foremost we're twitter mutuals it's
great to be here and i admire anyone
who's positive making a living
creatively the way that you are it's not
easy so i wrote my first book when i it
was like 2014 i was the head of a
nonprofit that you were talking about
yeah and i remember looking at my wife
and being like how the hell does anyone
make a living at just like being a
creative or writing because like i read
this book
and you know like i actually got a book
deal on the rest of it but it was like
not very large
[Laughter]
said i had a you know a job and so i was
like well i don't need this book or
creative income to pay my bills and
thank goodness for that so anyway i just
want to say like i just admire the heck
out of you and what you do thank you
that's so kind i actually i brought you
on the show to compliment me and tell me
that you admire me for my work so we've
checked that off the list i really
appreciate that and we're done
non-technical
okay andrew i have a question for you
that i think is it might be challenging
but go with me here how did you spend
your last day off my last day off was uh
this past weekend and i spent it it's
gonna sound so tech bro i i can't wait
okay okay here we go
i spent it at my house upstate
okay and i rode around on a onewheel
that was sent to me by the company
because i've been out in the bay at a
micro mobility conference and uh made
friends with you know the reps that were
there so i i spent the day off uh
messing around on this one wheel
relaxing with the family it was
delightful got a little bit of fresh air
went to a farm stand okay
you know apple cider doughnuts that kind
of thing great so fall vibes like a nice
fall weekend yeah fall weekend
compressed into one day uh because i
worked the previous day sure that makes
sense okay yes i will admit to you the
onewheel that's tech bro for sure but i
think you balanced it out nicely with
the rest of it oh thank you i try did
you fall did you stay up what was it
like i've never used one i did fall at
least once that happened like my
dismounts were most graceless things in
the world so it's funny you read the
instruction manual for the onewheel i
did read the manual so there's that okay
and there were different styles of
dismount and one style of dismount was
essentially just like jump off the thing
so i was like i'm totally gonna do that
version
is there like jump off chaotically
because that is absolutely how i would
be dismounting a one wheel yes that's
the way i did it i didn't skate as a kid
oh you did i did snowboard as an adult
so i kind of was cocky i was like oh put
me on this thing i'll be fine plus i i
demoed it at the micro mobility
conference it wasn't like my first time
on the thing wow i'm really impressed i
am trying to think i don't think i've
ever successfully been on a skateboard
or anything like that do you have to be
very balanced to do the onewheel have
you been on an e-scooter yeah so those
things are the easiest
yeah pretty sure of these oh yeah you
got handles no offense to anyone
listening to this but you have to be
pretty uncoordinated not to make it work
on one of those games i agree in my
opinion the one wheel is definitely
harder than that it's more akin to a
skateboard i would say okay uh and so if
you feel confident on skateboard i think
you'd be comfortable i don't feel
confident on a skateboard but i feel
confident period so maybe i will try it
out and we will see what happens have
you ever been known as the something
person well growing up i was one of the
only asian kids in my
school so i definitely grew up as the
chinese guy the asian guy
where did you grow up i was born in
schenectady new york which is upstate
and then i grew up
largely in in a suburb in northern
westchester i'm from like the northwest
corner of connecticut so just a couple
hours away
i mean i associate you with the bay area
now obviously i guess yes everyone does
okay so you mentioned you grew up in new
york state i love an east coaster and
let me ask you this do you have a
catchphrase or other words or phrases
that you or other people feel are
specific to you i'm told i have a very
specific laugh that then people are like
that's like the yang laugh
okay thinking about the catchphrases
what do i say that no one else does one
time on youtube someone wrote alexis has
the most jimmy fallon ass laugh uh is
that good i don't know but you know what
we'll take it
[Laughter]
no no i'm listening to your left and
you're like oh yeah i hear notes of
jimmy fallon sure well i mean it is uh
very jubilant uh jimmy does seem like a
very happy guy i mean yeah if jimmy
fallon wants to trade jobs i'm sure he
would do great at hosting non-technical
and i'm super down to host a late night
show oh wait i've got a word that i use
a lot but my team somewhat it's also
gonna make me seem like a tech bro
whatever
just lean in
it's sub-optimal
oh yes
pretty much what i when i want to say
something sucks but like you don't want
to
be negative no so you just say
suboptimal and then it's like okay like
we know what you mean
but you're not being
a pessimist about it i definitely also
say suboptimal i do think it's a tech
thing the one tech word that has made
its way into my actually i'll be totally
honest a lot of tech words have made
their way into my normal vernacular but
i find myself using the word optionality
in casual conversation you're not the
only one i thought your park in san
francisco video was brilliant in part
because it was so true to life
you are a true observer alexis you
observe us and then incorporate our
behaviors it helps that i'm one of us
you know i mean i worked in tech for
seven years so it definitely helped give
me a leg up i you know i lived in the
bay area uh for between one and three
months of the year for four or five
years in a row so i i spent wow amount
of time out there i thought you were
going to say i lived in the bay area for
between one and three months so i got it
and i was like honestly that's kind of
all you need you'll get it very quickly
yeah what was fun for me is i got to
hopscotch around the bay area too like
every time i came i'd stay in a
different neighborhood so that's awesome
[Music]
this is a happy festive time of year but
it's also a really tough time of year
for a lot of people the fact is there's
the holiday doldrums the holiday dumps
and that's particularly true for us all
given what's going on out there in the
world sometimes you think hey maybe i'll
call my family and friends but the truth
is
they don't know what to say
if you need someone to make you feel a
bit better someone who's actually going
to be looking out for your mental health
so take charge of your mental health
help achieve your own goals and check
out our sponsor betterhelp.com
yang betterhelp will help match you with
a licensed professional therapist
someone who actually knows what they're
talking about they'll be on demand for
you this is something i believe in very
very deeply and personally better help
has helped friends and family members of
mine that can help you too
i want you to start living a happier
life today and as a listener you'll get
10 off your first month by visiting our
sponsor at betterhelp.com
yang join over 1 million people who have
already taken charge of their mental
health again that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-com
yang happy holidays
so is there a fad and this could be
something work out something fashiony
cultural that you look back on
participating in that now makes you a
little cringy wow
so uh i'm 46 so i struggled with
my hair when i was growing up which i'm
not sure is an asian guy thing and so
there was definitely a phase in the
late 80s when i used product and it was
kind of big and
gelled up and spiky are we talking like
spikes up in the front like ross from
friends style
yeah something along those lines it's
kind of it was not a great look
i'm sure i think the photos are on the
internet somewhere
but i'm i'm not proud of that particular
phase i was like man that entire like
spiky hair
because
it's the opposite of effortless it's
like you know someone had to actually
invest in like time energy trying to
like get their hair like that which is
not what you want and it looks stupid so
you know it's like you exerted yourself
to look so optimal
oh yeah
i love it i know exactly what you mean
though i will say that i think that a
lot of work also goes into looking
effortless that's a big theory of mine
same with coolness i agree
if you can pull off the effortless look
kudos
there was a certain point in my life
hair wise where i just said here's what
it looks like and then there we go i
leaned in i don't resist it okay so
here's here's something i did that
some people you know who i went to high
school with remember i had this cowlick
in the back that would just like poof up
and i was trying to
manage it
and so one of the devices i discovered
was that if i matted it down with a
bandana then it would stay down so i
would sometimes wear a bandana and then
there was a particular look associated
with that obviously yes um and so then
some kids mocked me mercilessly sure
there's the 90s i mean you know because
they're
but you know it was mainly just to try
and you know keep the asian throw down
you know that was one of the things i
remember from that time wow
i i'll be honest i've never tried a
bandana look maybe i should give maybe
we should bring it back so if you had
the bandana on it would look like you're
a house painting or something i think
that's what uh you know what like i'm
just trying to manage my hair because
i'm hard at work yes exactly maybe i
teach art to kindergartners or something
like that and we were doing finger
painting i think that's the resulting
look if i wear a bandana yeah i mean
okay andrew what is the tiniest hill
that you're willing to die on so
something
inconsequential that you would really go
to bat for so i campaigned on this my
presidential race we really should get
rid of the penny the penny makes no
sense at all oh my god cost more than
one cent to produce it oh for sure it's
bad for the environment if someone's
using it it's just like a terrible use
of everyone's time anyone who's been
behind someone and this is the
stereotypes like the little old lady
who's like using pennies you're like oh
somebody yeah someone you know like end
this transaction
yeah
so but macro i looked at like the cost
of the penny is literally the tens of
millions of dollars a year like we just
got rid of it everyone's life would be
better that is so interesting and i
guess you know abe lincoln he's on the
penny right
love abe abe gets the nickel i have no
idea who's in the nickel we're kicking
someone off the nickel love honest abe
but you know the the penny's got to go
so that that's the title also on the
five dollar bill am i crazy that's true
he's got 500 times the penny
already
just and he'd much rather be on the five
shut it down honestly i think this is
the most compelling case for getting rid
of the penny yet which is aids got two
how did that happen yeah what's up with
that
well andrew i'll talk to my people and
surely i'll be able to get this done and
i'll keep you posted and you and i can
go to bat for this one together i mean i
ran on all these ideas and that was one
of i think we had like 175
like policy proposals just a casual 175
policy proposals well if you weren't
doing what you do now professionally
what would you be doing wow
such an interesting question i you know
so i'm at a very strange point in my
life and career alexis that you might be
able to relate to
i'm kind of myself for a living or i'm
sort of a public figure
yeah yeah yes yeah you know what i mean
which is weird because i had what you'd
consider a fairly normal job not that
long ago right so when you ask what i
would be doing uh you know i guess i
would
um have a normal job again but
i'm not even sure what that looks like
now
because your job is sort of
being andrew yang my job is kind of to
try to make positive things happen which
requires being andrew yang and i will
say it's uplifting where you know people
run into me on the street they're just
like yo andrew yang and and you know 99
times out of 100 they're very happy to
see me my job is to make people happy i
suppose but if you were to just like
turn off the last several years and i
was just doing my thing somewhere yeah i
mean i you know i'm a serial
entrepreneur so i'd find some problem to
solve what's a problem that i'm fairly
passionate about outside of fixing
democracy alleviating poverty
uh sensible crypto regulation data
rights yeah
i would probably do something on one of
those fronts yes okay that makes a lot
of sense you could hop right into crypto
there's plenty of opportunities you know
i'm gonna share this with you alexis
tell me so people ask me it's like hey
do you hold crypto blah blah and i
haven't held crypto except through uh
fund this whole time because i never
wanted anyone to accuse me of just
trying to
self deal profit boost
holdings etc that makes sense because i
wanted it to be clean that i'm
advocating for this it's not
self-interested anyway just sharing that
small thing no that's great i
now own some nfts because i made a video
about nfts and as a part of that i
launched a set of thumbnails from the
video as nfts it was really nice
yeah
yep so now i've got some eth
we're in the back that's great now
you're you're part of the the eth club
universe oh yeah thank god my lifelong
goal achieved okay how about this what
is something
non-work related that you're really
proud of i'm proud of the fact that i
can still this is going to sound bro
again i'm sounds good to bro i'm not
worried about it i'm proud of the fact
that i can crank out 25 to 30 push-ups
at a moment's notice
that's a lot of push-ups that sounds
like a lot that is right i i mean like
i'm proud of it so i guess i must think
so but
i'm proud of it i'm proud of you
well thank you alexis you're welcome
that's amazing i think i could do five i
could probably do five if really if push
up came to shove i could do five all
right is there a song that whenever you
hear it
takes you back in time to a specific
moment
there are so many songs that resemble
that so many
but you can pretty much pick just about
any song from the 80s and i'm just like
oh
i remember
that terrible junior high dance that
high school dancers
why were they terrible the junior high
dances because i was like the dorky
asian kid standing in the corner like
scared of everybody were you ever
popular in school so i first became
popular when i went to these nerd camps
called cty
yeah okay and then and then there i was
like the cool nerd or the relatively
cool nerd
so that was my first brush with uh
i was never popular so when i think of
junior high dances i also think of like
standing around
so my brush with popularity at nerd camp
got me very addicted to it i said i will
not rest until i achieved um i was
kidding
[Laughter]
on a lifelong mission to be popular
yes so the in terms of the songs the
memories okay i will definitely say this
because the cty thing they used to close
every dance at cty with american pie
great a classic yeah and so we would we
would sway to it so i have very strong
associations with that song
way to it
yeah like we've been getting the circles
and like oh okay it's very very campy
that's so cute yeah so i can tell you
what the cty anthems were from this era
yeah i would love to see so it was
forever young by alphaville like the
original of course not the remix fields
of gold by sting was there okay i don't
know that one that's our love triangle
by new order okay i might have screwed
up the sting timing that might be wrong
because i was also a counselor at this
camp oh really how many years were you
at camp i went to cty for
three or four summers as a kid like i
was 12 13 14 and 15. so at least four
summers and then i went back and was a
counselor when i was uh 19 and 20. oh
wow so this is a big part of your
adolescence oh yeah i mean because you
know what and the great thing too is
that like you know my parents were so
totally into it because it's like i was
learning stuff so they're like go go go
and then i would go and and be like yay
like run around and then as a and then
as a camp counselor it was a pretty good
summer job like they paid you and stuff
yeah of course so those are some of my
fondest memories at summer camp and as a
counselor so i could be figuring out
like messing up the chronology because
some of these songs might have been
played when i was a counselor these are
days by 10 000 maniacs was definitely on
the list so they're all these like
summer camp songs these are days reminds
me of a very specific summer in my life
because someone put it on a mix cd for
me was this a boy that likes you very
very much alexis
oh my god andrew the truth is it is a
boy that i had a huge crush on and i
wish that he liked me but he didn't he
just wanted to how could he make a mix
cd for you and not like you because that
is a sign of deeper
adolescence can you believe it also
would you believe he had the audacity to
go and like grow up and marry someone
else i would accuse this person of
leading you on in a very very serious
way because if i made a big cd for
someone it meant that i loved them
i'm gonna text him i'm gonna call him up
and i'm gonna be like nick andrew yang
and i have some thoughts okay yeah so if
you remember him making that big cd for
you then he owes you an apology an
explanation i know it's but that was
also totally the story of my like middle
school life high school life whatever is
just being hopelessly in love with boys
that were like we're cool as friends and
i was like dope awesome
that's like me liking girls mind is the
they wanting to be friends with me
okay so they were just like full pass
it's a full pass
exit through the friend zone that was
pretty much the way i was going i feel
you but look at us now both both on
non-technical
podcast empires verified on twitter i
mean the list goes on yes we send our
social media snippets to these people
that turned us down in junior high
school every day being like look what
you missed out on that's right you could
have had all of this i will let them
know
[Music]
okay i have a two-part question for you
first part is who would play you in a
movie about your life danger day kim oh
my god arty perfect answer i love him
he's an incredible actor the second part
is
is this movie going to be a biopic so
start of your life to present day or
should we focus in on a particular
chapter of your life that you think
would make a great movie to the extent
that there is a storyline that should be
made into a movie
it is my presidential campaign because
that was hilarious
so someone definitely needs to make this
movie i mean
and this is a plug too so the first
third of my book uh is about the
presidential campaign and i mean you
know like i thought it was pretty funny
um and then my campaign manager zach is
writing a full-on book about it uh
that's going to come out early next year
that
needs to be made into a movie of some
kind or a tv series that sounds great
it's just really really funny it's true
to life so i think that that if you were
to do a biopic most of my life is pretty
dull up until then well except for cty
where you crushed it uh i mean who the
hell wants to you know
watch like the least nerdy nerd running
around summer camp i mean that's not
exactly i think a lot of people i
honestly there's a lot of people there's
a lot of different types of content that
could get made but i agree that i think
your presidential run would make a
fantastic movie also your campaign
manager zack from connecticut good
people good people coming from
connecticut so that i think that that's
where it should go it'll be like daniel
day kim reflecting on
his uh rise to the presidency uh and
then people be like wait a minute you
didn't win and be like
yeah yeah yeah alternate ending this is
the director's cut
the director is andrew yang that's right
you know one of the jokes i told on the
trail was this is the simulation where
we win
i love that do you think we're living in
a simulation currently
like if push came to shove yes or no
what do you think mathematically you
would say we probably are
right and i've had some experiences too
that suggests that we are what's an
experience that suggests you're living
in a simulation well alexis keep keep in
mind you're talking to a guy who ran for
president united states and that is true
and became a nationally recognized
figure in the process so if anyone would
look up and say this is definitely a
simulation it would be someone like me
because my life has been so singularly
weird
of my own making sort of yeah but it's
it's not the kind of thing that works
ordinarily so from my perspective it
definitely feels like i'm living in some
either
fictionalized world of someone's
creation uh yes it's like something you
feel wow not at the same scale as you
but i really relate to that feeling
sometimes where i'm like i look around
and i think is this really is this okay
all right yeah i mean if it's a
simulation works for me i'm having a
great time
i'm so glad you're having a great time
i'm generally having a great time too i
mean that certainly there have been some
very stressful periods over the last
several years but generally you know
like super happy yeah i agree with that
well i think uh there's a phrase that i
really love which some of the stuff i i
know this makes me sound like a total
pollyanna but it's not happy people who
are grateful it's grateful people who
are happy yeah i love it i love that you
probably do the same thing i do which is
like i have a gratitude list and anytime
i'm down i just look at my phone and
it's a list of things i'm grateful for
like you know number one is
my wife my two is like you know
my my first son number three is my
second son
but then there's some random things on
there alexis yep like what my favorite
pizza place uh like there's one thing
there it says that i've achieved many of
my goals without having to destroy my
soul in the process like yeah i like
random things like that listed that i i
can still get out and play basketball
uh you know like somewhat competitively
uh yeah which which is something that
that i'm proud of so they're like things
where it's like oh i am grateful for
that i'm grateful for that too like you
know some of them are kind of minor and
dumb but yeah that always makes me feel
better to your point that grateful
people are happy so anyone listening to
this if you're down and i know sometimes
it's hard not to be down in this day and
age just make yourself a list of things
you're grateful for and add something to
it every once in a while at any time
yeah you're down at the dumps just refer
to it and will help and that's not just
me saying so that's like that's data
this stuff totally works right we're
nothing if not data backed so i would
agree 100
andrew okay so this is a question that
i've actually never asked before but i'm
curious what is the least expensive item
in your home that brings you the most
joy so i'm drinking a bubble tea as we
have this conversation oh really
expensive it's maybe like 490. i can
show it to you
let me see amazing what's your bubble
tea order almonds 30 sugar or less ice
okay if they have almond milk tea which
sure most do
and then after that just traditional
multi same i tend to skip bubbles i swap
i was gonna ask i swap in red beans for
bubbles oh really yes i just like red
beans i have a confession to make about
bubble tea which is that i
i don't like it it's too sweet for me we
must cease this conversation immediately
so
so the thing i would say alexis yeah
tell me if you if you want to is you can
get 30 sugar or zero percent sugar and
you might like it more what is it then
though like if i were to say no sugar it
sounds to me like it would just be tea
with milk yeah doesn't that sound
delightful
[Laughter]
you know what you got me there that's a
really good point okay so what is the
most memorable gift you've ever received
or given either or hmm
yeah gift eh
are you a good gift giver you know i
used to be above average and now we're
well well well below average
really poor i would say
so my wife just turned 40 and i managed
to rally and be like a reasonably good
husband okay and so like i i planned uh
you know a party and it was like uh nice
i had like you know fairly touching
speech fairly touching well okay amazing
it was funny too oh okay good but it's
been like a very very dry period for me
in terms of my gift-giving and
thoughtfulness which i i'm super
grateful that evelyn's let me get away
with this for a little while but before
then if you rewind way back i was pretty
good uh so i'm thinking about the things
i did when i was pretty good why do you
think you used to be better at giving
gifts than you are now so i used to be
kind of
an anxious shy introverted figure who'd
like look at people around me and like
be scared to talk to
girls and so then you'd become like
mildly obsessed with what other people
would like uh i suppose and so i was the
person who would be frankly probably
like a little bit cloying or creepy
[Laughter]
wait wait wait i'll do the invitation
like i see you like this thing
oh my god
i mean i wasn't like that but but but
that's like the imitation of someone
who's like a little bit too
attentive and i was very sensitive when
i was young so during that time
you know i would care a lot about
various things i would buy people you
know i remember as a teenager and like
buy girls i i i was crushing on like
jewelry that made no sense like stuff
like that oh wow you're like oh wow that
is pretty bad no no i'm just i was
honestly i was like for a teenager i
feel like buying jewelry that's like a
nice gift as we just established first
of all no one is buying me any gifts
other than mix cds to put me in the
friend zone but yeah i think jewelry
from a teenager is a nice gift but it
depends who it's coming from yeah now
i'm thinking about when i was younger
and then i'm thinking about when evelyn
and i were together before i entered my
now unmindful zone um and so what
changed for me
is that uh over the last several years
my
schedule and energies have just become
very very outward public facing and so
i'll just give you the the real life
example so i'm on the road running for
president
i come back to the family like you know
one two days a week and like i stick my
head in and then i have no idea what's
going on and if there's an occasion like
i don't know and if it and let's say it
was one of my child's birthday like i
know it was his birthday but it's that i
wasn't all like part of the planning so
i'd get there and there'd be like a
party that i just kind of showed up to
so
and again my family has been awesome and
and loving and supportive but i i
haven't exactly been winning like
husband of the year or dad of the year
competitions um over the last
several several years it would shock me
to learn that you had been how could one
singular person possibly do all of those
things at the same time thank you for
being understanding um really i just
thank evelyn for being understanding
over this past period of time so in
terms of
gifts that i am proud of or remember i
got my brother-in-law shinola watch i
was like proud of that at the time
shinola made in detroit yeah so as part
of venture from america i spent a lot of
time and i'm friendly with uh the
shannon team uh the founder is a great
guy
named uh tom cartsodis and he truly
started chinola just to try and you know
do something awesome and positive that's
great so there's a period when i bought
people shinola gifts and and i was proud
of that channel on the watch because i
think my brother-in-law really likes it
and he wears it to this day that's
really nice shinola was actually a part
of a gift-giving tradition at the last
company i worked for in tech patreon
where my manager who is now a good
friend of mine actually bremer morris
he's also been on the podcast he
bought all of us like new shinola
notebooks on our first day and so then
when i became a manager i started buying
new shinola notebooks for all of my
direct reports on their first day and so
it became a nice little tradition to
give like this nice notebook to your new
hire
that's lovely i really love shinola and
if you go to their their retail
locations it's uplifting uh and you know
that the stuff genuinely is made in the
u.s and i've been to the facilities in
detroit i think that they're doing
something really positive
[Music]
do you write a lot in a notebook do you
write by hand or do you type mostly i
definitely don't do any handwriting one
of the things that i've shared with some
folks is that when i was running for
president i actually didn't write
anything which i regretted but i didn't
have the energy like i was running for
president and at the end of the day i
wasn't like oh let me reflect that what
happened i was like
but then after i came off the trail i
wrote a lot and you know wrote this book
that came out a few weeks ago forward
that i'm very proud of
and and now that my life is kind of you
know someone in balance i try to write
but it's definitely not by hand i write
by hand because it slows me down slows
down my thinking i type too fast you
know why i typed you fast because i went
to a typing day camp when i was in
fourth grade what is your max speed this
is very important alexis i actually
haven't tested it in a long time but i
remember i tested it in college and i
think i hit like 110 words per minute or
something like that that is very very
fast is the narrative starting to take
shape that i was not a cool person
listen college i'm like 20 years old and
i remember one night being like damn i
wonder if i'm still a fast typist i a
hundred percent did the same things at
typingtest.com yeah
it's like like what can i max out at
wait now this is what i'm gonna do this
afternoon
i'm so scared to like this because my
fat fingers i'm sure have slowed down oh
no you gotta stay nimble stay agile
i am very proud to say that i was also
in that range where like i was landing
above 100 words per minute and it was a
point of pride okay i'm gonna have to
check out where mine is today because i
would be sad to learn if i've slept the
andrew yang alexis gay
typing test competition yes he's on and
what will be at stake
the championship of the internet yeah
exactly championship we'll get a
giant trophy made let's see if anyone
else wants to participate in the in this
nerdy competition i honestly there are
probably a lot of people that would want
to participate but just know that i will
take this so seriously like i would
practice a lot
i don't i don't do a lot of things
halfway
we could 100 make this a thing that
would be so fun
okay well i'll talk to zach yeah but we
could put this together that like do a
challenge like pick a charity of some
kind
of mistakes there could be a bedding
pool oh my gosh oh like this is great in
our in both of our closets amounts of
free time it has to be a bracket wait
that's brilliant we get 64 of us yes we
okay so we need 64 people to participate
have you ever put together a bracket for
something really really silly because i
have a great example of one that i've
done i know this would be my first what
what was yours i hosted a mario kart
tournament that's good that's good we
can draw on those skills now for this
alexis yeah i really i really went all
out for it i made seven layer rainbow
road jello shots
celebrated
oh because rainbow road of course did
you ever play mario kart yes okay on the
n64 i don't know
okay
you're like look someone handed me a
controller i did my like i was i was
there i played barbie yo she take the
wheel it happened it happened yeah so
the seven layer jello shots were because
rainbow road is the like famous final
race in the cup uh and so that it had to
be done so when i'm thinking about this
this championship this competition
so one of the the major variables we'd
have to determine is whether these
contests take place in person or
virtually i mean virtually be a lot
easier yeah well virtually would also be
nice because you could just take a
screenshot of your score and share it oh
my gosh you're right you just do it in
real time uh yeah but you know so you
and i know this too though but there
would have to be some kind of referee
because 100 if you have a typing test
passage you
literally can just memorize the passage
and then get better at it like you know
what i mean i bet you you did this when
you were on it so it has to be like a
passage that both of you get sprung on
you don't know what it is
and then you both do it you know what i
mean like it's not like i just produced
a screenshot okay that's a great point
also in this scenario it needs to be
proctored okay it needs to be like
people are on zoom and then there's
another person on zoom proctoring the
situation the prompt is then shared on
the screen that's what would have to be
done
this is we have to do something like
this it has to be
synchronous it has you know there has to
be
it it's not some take-home test [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it sounds like we have a lot of good
optionality though here for different
paths we could take okay all right
continuing i'm feeling optimistic
what is something
that you're really good at that it would
surprise people to learn about you so we
know you're good at basketball we know
you're good at push-ups or that you can
do 20 to 30 of them what is something
that would surprise most people wow what
am i good at so i'm not good at a lot of
things um you know you want to make a
list of things that i'm really bad at
it's like very sure that's not true
but i feel the same way if someone asked
me this question i'd be like uh
i think i would probably say mario kart
honestly so so people would expect me to
be good at video games which by the way
i i was pretty good at video games oh
really what was your game of choice well
so i just rolled up to like a miss
pac-man machine the other day and you
know like wasn't like a crazy like high
score but i like broken i knew i could
so yeah that sort of thing so but that i
i think that wouldn't surprise people
because i remind them of that person
wait can i ask you a quick video game
question were you a tetris player yes i
wasn't exceptional at tetris but i did
play and you know it got those blocks in
the brain kind of phenomena
that's why i asked because i don't want
to say like i am a huge tetris person
it's not like i play all the time now
but i love
tetris i love it i played it so much in
high school that when i would close my
eyes to sleep like i would see i would
see the blocks yeah seeing the blocks
it's a real condition i know it's called
block scopia
um something i'm good at that people
would be surprised by
um
so i'm sort of projecting on to what
people think i'd be good at i was gonna
say i'm good at scrabble but i think
most people would know would like kind
of guess that yeah
i feel like people who've written books
word games it wouldn't surprise me to
learn they're good at them yeah you know
i probably come across as literate
something i've always thought about you
andrew yang is in fact literate it's
like a major breaking news scoop on the
pod i'm an adequate juggler really
that does surprise me i was not
expecting that what kind of stuff can
you juggle oh just no nothing
spectacular just you know i can juggle
three objects of like similar size for
some period of time
again the key word being adequate why
can you juggle it's just i was on the
high school tennis team and so you know
we were just like boarding on tennis
courts all the time and so just like
juggle tennis balls and then have mild
competitions
[Music]
andrew we've arrived at a very exciting
moment in this episode of non-technical
do you think you're ready yes yes i love
that answer we've arrived at the
lightning round okay first question for
you coffee or tea
milk tea
do you drink coffee at all i like coffee
if i order something it would probably
be something like a decaf mocha it's
just i try and avoid hard caffeine i
started martial arts when i was a
teenager and that was one of the rules
of the dojo so it just kind of stuck
with me really oh i never knew that i
would not do well at a dojo yeah i guess
not
at least not at that dojo i can tell you
some fun things so it's like master kim
one of his things was you would say did
i miss command or did you misunderstand
and then the correct answer was always i
misunderstood
oh of course oh good old master kim
are you an ios or an android user ios
forever and always no no i was a pc guy
for a long time and then i was an
android person for a while as a
blackberry guy i had a palm pilot i had
a bunch of devices
had the opposite of the midas touch
where any platform i touched then like
disintegrated around me and i was like
oh i have to learn something new i
actually learned that palm script with
the stylist oh yes
oh my god i haven't thought about that
in like maybe 20 years i know exactly
what you're talking about yes so at some
point i got an iphone and and uh
and mac and the rest of it do you have a
favorite board game risk i always liked
risk yeah do you still play we play
board games for the kids for sure we've
been playing monopoly more than risk
though which i am i'm cool with i mean i
like monopoly we have whatever reason
reason we have at least three versions
of monopoly in the house
what's your favorite monopoly version
well there was one that that's like a
set of characters they really like i
think it might be super mario yeah it
might be like a like a super mario
themed monopoly wait that's so cool do
your kids play mario kart they have for
sure yeah okay they could probably beat
me to be totally honest i feel like kids
you don't think so my kids aren't very
good at it i don't think okay
have you ever read a book twice yes for
sure any particular one come to mind oh
it's gonna make me a tech bro again um i
used to really really love the book
built to last by jim collins jerry porus
and i read that thing like five times oh
sure i think there's no shame in loving
a good tech book a good tech business
book there are many that i consider some
of my favorites oh good so fun
yeah the like the the canon crossing the
chasm
innovator's dilemma et cetera et cetera
yeah yeah exactly
okay do you have a pump up song yes i
have a bunch of pop-up songs because i
ran for president um sure
campaign theme song was returned to the
mac and that always gets me in a good
mood i played this florence in the
machine song the dog days are over
sometimes to get pumped up i love that
song
those two come to mind dog days are over
is an excellent pump up song when i was
at nyu i took a songwriting class and we
had to bring in a song to analyze and
that was the song that i chose wow look
at that green mine's all fun fact i feel
like you and i could be friends i think
we could be friends too
that's actually why i do the show this
is just so that i can make friends with
cool people who i think i have a lot in
common with well it's working
it's working good i'm happy to hear it
okay this is sadly my final question for
you what would you title your memoir
well i don't know
i think this is a hard question because
you'll you'll probably have a memoir
don't you think it's interesting alex
i've written a few books now
and in each book i had to write a
chapter about
myself and i didn't enjoy it and so
but it's funny there are now three
different versions of chapters about
myself because in order to you know just
to have some narrative connection or
flow it's like well let me just tell you
what like who the hell i am and what
i've been up to i wouldn't want to make
an entire book about that so like it
ends up being about these ideas you know
um like the my latest book is about
trying to make our democracy work by
advancing from the duopoly but if i had
to write a memoir i mean some of the
things that come to mind i i don't have
a ready title to be honest with you i
feel kind of lame about given that i i
should should be on this i don't think
that's lame at all i actually don't have
a good answer to this question myself
which surprises a lot of people but i
think it's because it's very hard for me
to visualize writing a memoir
like i wouldn't want to write a book
about myself i would write a book i
don't know if i would want to write a
book about me i am with you i'm going to
share with you something that this might
be deeply personal but it was so i i
just read a book by an author named jay
caspian kang who's coming on my podcast
uh who wrote a book called the loneliest
americans and it's about asian american
identity and he
put something in there that made me
laugh out loud when i read it really he
was talking about a particular guy named
named doug who's like you know trying to
make it in hollywood and then he said
about doug this story is pathetic
but most asian american stories are
pathetic
and when i read this i like laughed out
loud and then showed my wife evelyn and
then we had like uh you know she also
got a chuckle out of it she didn't find
it as funny as i did so then i talked to
the author yeah jake hang about this be
like hey this is a line in your book um
you know what were you thinking when you
wrote this book and i told him like you
know i found it really funny he said you
know andrew it's like no one gives a
[ __ ] about what's going on with uh like
the internal lives of asian dudes like
it's just not like a thing anyone cares
about he said that he felt this deep
ambivalence about writing a book about
something that the thesis is that no one
gives a [ __ ] about wow that was like the
circularity of it wow i thought that was
really interesting and kind of profound
and so then when you asked me to like
imagine my memoir or whatever like i
totally draw blank
in part because i can't imagine writing
a book about myself in that way um and i
think it has something to do with that
conversation with jay
where it's like so and so this could be
something you know like so i ran for
president uh and mayor and so you're
going around doing things i'd like you
know a message and a vision for the
campaign its goals and the rest of it
and their ups and downs there's some
adversity and whatnot and one of the
reasons i think that i was able to make
headway and this is true i think
probably for a lot of creatives is that
you just like kind of set aside and
compartmentalize the negative and just
focus on the pause and be like all right
you know what like that didn't go our
way it's fine it's like you know blah
blah blah keep going
iterate yeah iterate and the rest of it
and i think that mindset is highly
practical and helpful and useful
when you're trying to catalyze a popular
movement or you know like
like change like a broken system
i think it does hew away from
trying to talk about yourself a lot you
know what i mean it's like you're almost
prepared or conditioned in a certain way
that makes you capable of some things
but maybe more uncomfortable with others
wow that's really interesting and the
comparison of creative work that
resonates with me is that how much of
what i'm creating is an expression of
myself versus just something that i'm
creating yeah and it's uncomfortable too
because so the first time i wrote a book
back in 2014
you know the book wasn't about me but it
was about like these ideas for yeah mark
and the rest of it and it feels very
very personal because you're like
talking to my new book and you're pretty
much like hey buy my book read my book
it's good yeah and it's impossible
not to take that personally
like if someone's like hey
i you know have no interest in your book
or
whatever it is like like it does make
you really sad you're like oh but i like
worked hard on it the rest of it and so
i really feel for what you just said
which is like you do this thing and you
identify with it very personally because
it's impossible not to it's like you
know i [ __ ] created this thing like i
invested time and energy
i will say though when people don't like
the things that i make i don't consider
it an attack on me even though it is me
i isolate myself from that entirely i
think that isn't me that is a thing that
i made and then i try to focus my energy
back to all right let's make the next
thing that is very very productive and
healthy
i think it's the only reason i'm able to
put my face on the internet
because otherwise oh my god
what would i do
what a deed what a deep
yeah i mean it is very very healthy i do
the same thing in most instances the
book is sort of an exception because you
know it's such a labor yes yes yes and
you know and you feel like you put a lot
of yourself into it whereas if you know
someone doesn't care about you know a
tweet of mine i was like who cares
that's a really great point and good
advice for us all okay well i kind of
hope based on everything we just talked
about that you do write a memoir i'll be
totally honest i think it would be
i think it would be good well for what
it's worth my new book is i would say
about 40 percent memoir so
really
so you can check it out and be the judge
that would be fantastic and speaking of
your incredible book andrew thank you so
much for coming on non-technical this
has been such a treat where can people
find more about you online go to
andreang.com
or forwardparty.com uh it's got
information about what i'm up to now
the
book the podcast the events the
political movement join us let's fix
things yeah andrewyang.com is probably
the easiest way
amazing okay and you can find me at
yayalexusgay on twitter and instagram or
at non-technical pod on twitter andrew
one more time i cannot thank you enough
for taking the time to talk to me today
you kidding we're best buds and i am
going to beat you at the typing test and
then you will not be thanking me i am
literally going to start practicing
immediately there's no chance thank you
so much i'll talk to you soon bye bye
[Music]
you